هناك واقعتان حدثت اليوم في الثاني عشر من
ربيع الاول داخل المساجد يجب ادانتهما
بشده لان هؤلاء قتلوا المصلين داخل
المساجد
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم اكثر من 56 قتيلا وعشرات
الجرحى في تفجيرين استهدافات تجمعا
لمحتفلين بالمولد النبوي في اقليم
بلوشستان ومسجدا قرب مدينه بيشاور
والسلطات تتعهد بالقضاء على الارهابيين
والتصدي لممولهم
في ظل المعارك المشتعله بمناطق عده في
الخرطوم المتحدثه باسم برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه تحذر في مقابله مع الجزيره من
خطوره الوضع الانساني نتيجه انعدام الامن
الغذائي وتقول ان هناك عقبات امام الوصول
للمحتاجين بسبب الاقتتال بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
موسكو تولين اسقاط مسيرات اوكرانيه في
مدينتي كالوجا وكوسك الروسيتين وكييف تقول
ان قتلى سقطوا في قصف روسيا على خيسون في
حين يبحث بوتين مع قائد سابق في باجنر
تشكيله وحدات قتاليه تطوعيه يمكنها اداء
مهام متعدده خصوصا في اوكرانيا
تقرير للامم المتحده يكشف ان الامريكيين
من اصول افريقيه يتعرضون لعنصريه ممنهجه
من الشرطه والقضاء وان ارسى العبوديه
متجذر بشكل كبير في الاجهزه والمؤسسات
الامريكيه وذلك بعد استماع المحققين
لشهادات وصفت بالصادمه لضحايا وناشطين كما
اكدت تحقيق ان السجناء منهم يعاملون
بطريقه مهينه مطالبا باجراء اصلاحات عاجله
الى اللقاء